[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 350 km au nord de damas tout proche de
la frontière turque
alep est la seconde métropoles urbaines
de la syrie avec plus d'un million
d'habitants la cité rivalisent par ses
activités industrielles et commerciales
avec les grandes capitales du
moyen-orient à l'epp s'enorgueillit
d'être l'une des plus anciennes cités du
monde
c'est sous ces monuments témoigne de sa
richesse et de son passé capital à l'aip
le fut sous la domination des mythes
amiens dei type des assyriens des arabes
et plus près de nous sous le mandat
français
[Musique]
pour nous rappeler ce rôle de capitale
la citadelle qui dresse orgueilleusement
ses remparts au dessus de la ville
romains et byzantins les dit fier des
qualifs de damas la forty fier lui
permettant de résister aux envahisseurs
mongols pendant les croisades beaudoin
de roi de jérusalem il fut emprisonné
pendant deux ans tout comme un certain
nombre de chefs francs
[Musique]
avec ses 300 bosquet et médersas alep
constitue un centre islamique religieux
de première importance
mais sa population est à l'image de la
syrie actuelle d'islam n'a pas absorbé
les minorités religieuses et ethniques
les chrétiens sont encore nombreux près
du quart de la population
les arméniens qui ont pu sur le génocide
tueur ont leur quartier près de l'église
et leur communauté est très vivante à
alep si les musulmans forment la majeure
partie de la population
les chrétiens ont entre leurs mains de
négoce qui fit la fortune de la ville
grâce à sa situation à l'extrémité
occidentale de la route du golfe
persique et de la méditerranée
la syrie est un pays en voie de
développement aux industries nouvelles
un marché de combat où les grandes
puissances économiques essaie de placer
leurs marchandises la france n'est pas
absente de 7,8
un exemple de réussite avec la compagnie
air france qui a réussi une implantation
touristique importante avec la création
et l'ouverture de quatre grands hôtels
méridien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]